c'est la saint valentin le romantisme a
droit de cité partout à bagdad où la
violence est quotidienne les amoureux
célèbre 6e 14 février le jour où l'on
s'échange traditionnellement des cadeaux
et bouquets de fleurs et l'amour des
beaux mots pour dire ses sentiments à
paris les messages s'affichent sur grand
écran et dans les journaux les petites
phrases sont battre les coeurs alexandra
garde patrice brugère n'a jamais rêvé de
voir son amour projeté en lettres de feu
à la foule entière aujourd'hui ce rêve
est devenu réalité pour 2000 parisiens
qui comme frédéric waller message
d'amour des filets depuis 6 heures ce
matin sur 170 panneaux de la capitale
façon sms juin
j'ai un double message à faire passer
c'est c'est un message d'amour en fait
pour la ville de paris pour une femme
que j'aime mais avec qui je souhaite
rester durablement
l'idée est poétique le principe simple
et gratuit pour réaliser son rêve
frédéric a simplement inscrit son mot
d'amour sur le site internet paris.fr le
destin a fait le reste en tirant au sort
informatiquement son message parmi
plusieurs milliers c'est une déclaration
qu'on fait devant tout le monde
mais en même temps c'est un peu caché
ses six relativement anonyme il ya que
la personne qui la reçoit tu peux la
comprendre
c'est ce mélange de surprise et puis
d'anonymat qui m'a plu plus traditionnel
christophe a préféré le papier et les
annonces de libérations qui jouissent
depuis quinze ans d'une certaine
réputation
le coût est plus élevé de 30 à 75 euros
selon le nombre de mots mais l'effet
assuré 5 millions de lecteurs liront
aujourd'hui le quotidien pour y
découvrir la tonalité amoureuse de
médecine écriture assez fraîches a fait
un vrai retour au romantisme et au côté
très très très peur de plus que dans les
années 80 où le discours pouvait
parfois plus crue dans les propos et
crise le sentiment amoureux est un art
difficile mais qui sera récompensée
cette année
chantal thomass fait partie du jury qui
élira les trois plus beaux messages
choses très différentes les unes des
autres et les choses très simples je
t'aime très simple et il ya des choses
très drôle
des mots d'humour c'est mignon mais
beaucoup de choses très romantique sms
ou papier gagnant ou perdant peu importe
finalement car aujourd'hui l'important
c'est d'aimer